hey guys Ryan right here okay and we're  gonna have a little adventure at the  park today it's gonna be fun we're gonna  have a good old time things are gonna  get a little bit what did you just fart  Sally no you're not fooling anybody  when you say that that was a natural  disaster you're lying I'm not lying I  didn't fart look Sal it wasn't an  earthquake it wasn't a typhoon because  what's really happening out there is  that you're hiding something and it's  gonna send us back to the Stone Age  we're waking something a nuclear test  they weren't test we were trying to kill  it can we kill it the arrogance of man  is thinking we're controlled danger not  the other way around  it's Godzilla